c'est à dire pression la bête à la
période de la mue un bon alors il encore
très peu et le magazine challenge était
léger ensuite on a eu notre service
assez acerinox qu'on appelle la sarkozie
tissu une autre série qu'on appelle
série noire avec 3 remplissage en
tissage léger ou anormales et fort alors
là il ya 70% de vifs et 30% de 9 le neuf
c'est le même river mépris sur la bête
tuée oui je crois que c'est une activité
originale et puis bon c'est douillet
en plus c'est vrai que leurs activités
et oubliettes ça montre un petit peu
leur côté sympathique côté affectueux
leur côté presque intime avec les gens
autrement c'est l'ouverture à l'ancienne
que vous voyez enfin si vous écoutiez la
demande n était alors purnell pur coton
ces pourritures l'ancienne comme
officier autrefois moi juste et les
petites fourmis un travail via leçons
précieuses à leçons mais si moi j'ai une
belle coin que ça fait des années que
oui c'est un très beau aussi
c'est une rosace comme gens choisissent
leurs cousins traîner les lits des
grands parents je pourrais vous donner
l'exemple par exemple d'un berceau un
petit berceau donc anciens au point de
vue dimension évidemment rien de
standards et pour réaliser un matelas
adapté à ce petit berceau il fallait
absolument rencontrer les soeurs leur
demandait de faire ce travail qu'elles
ont fait avec diligence et à travail de
qualité exceptionnelle de neuvième faire
travailler la bonne et qu'il ne
chanterait que tu l'as eu de lewy par un
catalogue puis aussi un cartel oui on
s'entraide entremont aspects
où
représenter dieu pour ces femmes pour
qu'elles s'y donnent toute leur vie et
qu'elle accepte de vivre dans ces
conditions très très limité le fait de
ne pas sortir pour moi est quand même
quelque chose de très très particulier
s'enfermer et puis c'est tout de même de
ça qu'il s'agit s'enfermer pour tout
consacrées à dieu pour chercher dieu est
certainement le trouver le plus ou moins
facilement un sur une vie peut se passer
bien des choses des hauts et des bas
on
m
à la suite des lois sur le congrégation
de 1903 les carmélites de nancy se
réfugier en belgique en 1923 quand elles
peuvent enfin rentrer en france
elles sont devenues trop nombreuses et
décide de se scinder en deux carmel
c'est dans un ancien établissement de
clarisse situe à verdun qu'une partie
d'entre elles s'installent aujourd'hui
elles sont 17 à y vivre et y prier et à
y travailler car les carmélites de
verdun travaille beaucoup
depuis 1948 elle confectionne pour la
clientèle meusienne et bien au delà des
couvertures de laine des édredons
découvre au pied et autres accessoires
de literie dans les années 80 poussé par
une concurrence asiatique de plus en
plus pressante
elle se spécialise dans la couette en
duvet haut de gamme c'est le tissu le
plus léger qui soit donc c'est assez
apprécié un certain nombre de personnes
qui qui préfère mettre le prix pour une
fois être très légère ça que ça durera
longtemps et que la qualité le rapport
qualité prix
et vous en 1978 les soeurs dot leur
atelier d'une structure juridique adapté
c'est la création officielle des
ateliers plume laine une sarl au capital
de 50 mille francs
une démarche plutôt novatrice pour un
monastère
il y a un an et demi les carmélites de
verdun ont eu le bonheur de voir arriver
deux novices dans un contexte de crise
profonde des vocations et de
vieillissement général des moniales
ce fut un grand événement pour toute la
communauté
ça s'est passé au lycée dans un bâtiment
s'est lui avait dit faire ce bâtiment
j'étais dans mon petit convoi
je vivais une période très très
difficile très difficile
oui de remise en cause de deux vraiment
et là bas j'ai rencontré de crise qui ne
me dire combien il m'avait toujours
migrants bien aimé mais combien ils
désiraient mon amour
à partir de ce moment j'ai dit seigneur
je te donne ma vie si tu ne veux plus
dans le mariage tout ça mais si tu veux
plus dans la vie religieuse celui qu un
abandon total et avant ça pour moi
c'était clair que ce serait le mariage
les pieux
je pense avoir minimum 3 enfants je suis
arrivé au carmel un petit peu par hasard
entre guillemets je cherchais un lieu
offert une retraite et puis bon pas
comme ça lui est arrivé et l'ebit jours
que j'ai passés dans ce lieu pour moi ça
a été comme une révélation de me dire
mais ce que vivent ces femmes là ce qui
fait le coeur de leur vie c'est à dire
l'oraison cette prière silencieuse et
ben c'est ce que je vis et je savais pas
que ça s'appelait l'horizon et est
vraiment pour moi ça a été une
découverte
on se fait beaucoup conseillé parce que
moi j'ai absolument pas une formation de
nids contente de l'île d'yeu et encore
moins de gérante
mais bon ben on sait de par des gens de
l'extérieur et puis aussi entre nous on
certaines ont plus de compétences que
d'autres bon ça n'empêche pas les ennuis
ou enfin dix ans qu'on essaie de les
vivre
bah moi généfique en mai malgré ses murs
de sa charge quand même bon les choses
et moi je suis contente de vivre ça
parce que au niveau de la solidarité je
me dis les petites entreprises
maintenant elles sont dans le même cas
que nous et encore bon bah nous on a de
la chance d'avoir le carmel par exemple
puisque sinon des ouvrières bon
risquerait de faire grève s'ils étaient
syndiqués
avant de rentrer la sambre à mes yeux ça
serait bien que tu saches coûte alors je
me souviens je les fais une europe qui
pendant laquelle a été plus alors avec
un patron qui maman savez bien coudre
donc enfin je peux pas dire que c'était
pas du tout mon métier rentrée mais vous
avez chatté dactylo crédit agricole la
caisse régionale
c'est sûr qu'il ya fossé entre entre ce
qu'on vit ici
et puis la culture de la société
actuelle c'est sûr en même temps oui en
même temps ce que les soeurs vivaient
avant on entrait en entrant au noviciat
en entrant enfin le carmel était
beaucoup plus strictes
il y avait certaines coutumes qui sont
beaucoup moins présente aujourd'hui donc
qui nous pèse pas comme bon en même
temps si notre culture aussi elle était
peut-être plus préparés à vivre ça que
nous aujourd'hui je ne sais pas mais
c'est sûr qu'il ya beaucoup à aller
c'est comment dire ça
il ya une certaine solitude affective à
vivre ou carmen et que peut-être ce
qu'il peut être le plus difficile à
vivre encore ça dépend des moments mais
je me dis le reste c'est des choses
qu'on laisse mais qui nous touche
peut-être moins
intimement profondément quoi cette
solitude lama faut apprendre à la gérer
à l'accueillir à l'assumer et à
l'assumer en enfin pas que ça nous ça
nous rend fernand en vivant
s'épanouissant
regarde assez mûrs les nouveaux baptisés
qui porte son nom qu'ils vivent de leur
baptême dans le milieu
regarde un seigneur les ans qui doute
été de recherche au carmel de verdun la
journée est ponctuée par les offices
religieux
à 7h15 après une heure de raison les
laudes à 8 heures l'eucharistie à 11h55
leurs médianes à 17h va être suivie de
la deuxième heure quotidienne de raison
et à 20h30 le dernier office du soir
les repas sont prises en silence parfois
accompagnées d'une lecture d'un journal
chrétien
la rencontre fraternelle qui suit le
repas de midi est un moment de détente
prisé de tout même si au carmel détente
ne rime pas avec oisiveté
là je me sens proche même si nous
travaillons dans des conditions assez
privilégié parce que nous ne sommes pas
salariés nous ne sommes pas ne pas peur
d'être licencié ou des choses de genre
mais je me sens proche du monde du
travail
j'ai peu travaillé avant d'entrer le mot
faillite ou même travailler et pour moi
c'est très important
apparemment
je pense que de toute façon au carmel il
ya une vie de pauvreté qui s'exprime par
le fait de gagner sa vie de travailler
pour vivre et pas simplement de compter
sur la générosité de l'église disons
pour vivre ça nous empêche aussi de
planer je pense être affrontée au réel
et même d'avoir des difficultés trouver
des débouchés ou des choses aux gens ce
qu'ils n'existaient pas peut-être à 50
ans pour le mettais autres et je pense
qu une vie de prière pour qu'elle soit
comprise et qu'elle soit même cohérente
avec
la foi ne peut pas se vivre en dehors du
réel je pense que les réels ça passe par
le travail
à
regardez contempler le plus beau des
enfants des hommes se laisser fasciner
par lui botter qui surpassait toute
beauté chante thérèse d'avila
pourquoi m'avoir blessés pourquoi
m'avoir blessé sinon pour crier à toute
créature que vous la convoitée je pense
que 1/4 dermit c'est quelqu'un qui en
fait est brûlée par le désir du salut du
monde avec le christ ici toutes les
soeurs doivent être amis toutes doivent
s'aimer se fit rire et s'entraider
scande-t-elle avec force à dieu et la
doute les soeurs sans en accepter une
seule celle difficile
oui c'est difficile de suite on a mis
dans les selles difficile c'est la vie
c'est que tout pareil et une grande
capacité d'intériorité
cet équilibre est d'autant plus
nécessaire pour une carmélite qu'elle
est destiné à vivre toujours dans la
même communauté avec les mêmes soeur
dans le même mille 2 et la même maison
avec les mêmes horaires
alors tout ça faux faux faux dit aunis
quand même
c'est salle carmen ça passe beaucoup
d'ardeur des petites choses l'amour
qu'on y met bombe
là aussi j'ai prié pour la cliente qui
aura cette couette sur la connais pas
bon c'est vrai quand même que parmi et
les clients qu'on reçoit souvent il ya
une autre dimension commerciale et il
est pas rare que des soeurs à l'accueil
beau reçoivent des des demandes de
prières et puis bon des chambres parle
un peu plus donc c'est disant que c'est
autre chose quel magasin quoi
tous les monastères top se suréquiper
pour arriver à sauver la prière étant
donné que nous avons peu de temps de
travail par jour 5 heures au maximum et
du travail des coupes est confronté à
une baisse des commandes due à une
concurrence effrénée contre laquelle
elles ne peuvent lutter à armes égales
les carmélites de verdun ont ouvert il
ya peu un deuxième atelier tiges b
consacrés à la fabrication dostie elles
ont pu récupérer les machines du carmel
de nancy qui fermait ses portes après
avoir dispersé ses 11 dernières soeurs
nous n'avons aucune subvention et là il
ya beaucoup d'idées à faire tomber parce
que souvent on nous dit mais vous êtes
subventionné vous allez à l'évêché
douzaine quelque chose dans notre cas du
tout le poids mouche et n'a pas de
moyens plus mais elle nous donne avait
prévu 1300 euros par mois et un retrait
de oui à peu près de 4800 euros
et puis moi je prends à peu près 2000
attiches départ moi aussi j'ai mensuelle
de 120 euros
oui pas plus sympa plus parce que oui on
dépense pas tout si vous voulez on a
fait quand même un petit peu pour
l'entretien courant la maison les par
les contrats vont évidemment mais un
petit peu d'autres tiens on a quand même
un petit peu un petit un tout petit tout
petit capital si vous voulez mais avec
la bourse actuellement peut pas les
touches c'est tout a fondu
selon lui si la fondatrice du carmel de
verdun installe sa communauté en 1924
dans une ville traumatisée par la grande
guerre
un jour deux heures faisant le jardin
des champs jardins qui était leur
habitat épouvantable une se retrouve un
objet rond elle dit à l'autre comme on
dirait une bande l'us cagnes et elle
lance la faire sur les pierres déjà
extrait tu étais une grenade qui n'a pas
explosé
les carmélites peuvent enfin défricher
tranquillement leur terrain qui fait à
peu près un hectare pour y planter
fruits et légumes et il y ait levé
quelques poules dont elles vendent les
eaux d année sereine joyeuse même grâce
à l'afflux de nouvelles postulantes
mais la deuxième guerre mondiale éclate
les soeurs se réfugie à lyon très vite
la prieure décide de retourner à verdun
déclaré zone interdite
le gros de la communauté voulant la
rejoindre se retrouve un jour sur un
quai de gare de la meuse
il ya bien un allemand qui surveillaient
le petit portillon ils nous voient ils
nous dit vous religieuse
oui à moi père blanc jeudi père blanc du
cardinal lavigerie
oui au priez pour nous allons grosse
malheur aux malheurs il lui a ouvert la
porte
on croirait pas si c'était pas un rat
côté par interpol alors nous avons aidé
affirmant on a pu prévenir nous nous
étions et le fromage et envoie son
camion dont qui arrive qui nous change
de monde en camion et puis loup
déclation de joie et enchanta magnificat
et il se retourne vers 12h30 heure les
fromages ça chante pas
en 1948 sur les conseils de la famille
d'une jeune postulantes
les carmélites décide de se lancer dans
la confection et la réfection de
couverture pour assurer leur subsistance
à peu près tout la meuse couchait sur
nos couvertures de laine y compris le
sous préfet c'était on était très connu
ça oui et puis c'était bien parce que on
voyait lui certes travail est alléchante
rien charge est entendue mais mais
travailler ce ça faisait quelque chose
aux jeunes depuis l'événement du concile
à la con s'il est c'est un événement
considérable pour la partie de crever
loin de là
et ça y est ça a été très important pour
nous et c'était déjà le cas ni ski qui
avait compris beaucoup de choses
l'hôtel face au peuple
bon ben j'étais d'église qui sait qu'il
serait inséré dans le monde qui sera
insérée dans les livres